this interviews gonna be like you
talking while I look at my phone and
then how do phones work hi I'm Daniel
shiner and I'm Daniel Wong we wrote and
directed Swiss Ironman and we're here to
show you our phones sorry I'm
stopping at seven here's the headline on
this ESPN screenshot no joke
says Swedish footballer sent off for
farting during match and then it even
has like a screenshot of him or photo as
a Photoshop like a soccer player with a
big dark cloud yeah with like a big like
nuke nuclear mushroom cloud I have a
crippling addiction to internet trailers
so the last thing I have Google was the
Morris from America movie trailer
because I saw a 24 had released it was
like I wanna see that this year yeah a
24 nother a 24 movie I was it's pretty
solid should I should we just hold up
well and play the trailer for three my
last text message was yes Father please
bother I made it for you because my
friend Randy littky who's a comedian
said he was going to see the movie
tonight
and I told him I hope it doesn't suck
and he was like oh do you know something
I don't should I even bother and then I
had to backtrack no but actually go
please Brandi go yes I literally don't
get it so I just make a new alarm
basically every day so let's count them
50 well you have 2% way yeah okay I got
to eight that was twenty forty forty-one
I have 41 alarms and I don't understand
why it's like I understand this whole
thing I guess before you check I don't
think I use angry face I do this a lot I
don't know why I think that might be
able to do someone I do I like to do
every ethnicity
yeah this is a white guy to have that
yeah it's a white guy interesting yeah
what's the save him you know I don't
want to post my last Instagram was your
lesson cerium it was those me face
swapping with my girlfriend I'm wishing
myself a happy birthday
okay what was the last thing you search
for in private